I've been working over a decade with low-wage
working families.
Above immigration, above housing, above healthcare,
the number one issue that is most important
to working families is the education of their children
The Parent Worker Program is a collaboration
between UCLA Labor Center and IDEPSCA.
Specifically, our program Mujeres en Accion, our household worker project.
The Parent Worker Project aims to support
parents who are household workers better serve
the needs of their kids.
My mother is a domestic worker, so I know
this from the work that I do, but I also know
it in my personal life.
Domestic workers are really interested in
participating in their communities
Parents are learning about how to get involved
in their children's education, how can they
be the agents in making sure that their kids
have all the opportunities that all children have.
And while parents are learning those skills, their
children are also working with tutors from
UCLA.
UCLA has been able to train UCLA students
that share similar backgrounds as these families.
So there's already that cultural connection.
We had a trip to UCLA.
Many families had never visited a university
in the US.
It was great because then being there with
their kids they could have a conversation
about the future.
A key component of this project is for parents
to train other working parents around advocacy
to provide the best education for their children.
When parents are able to participate in the
education of their children, the academic
outcomes for those kids are higher.
When we started this project, 60% of the kids
in this area did not graduate from high school.
Those numbers are changing.
It's a very empowering thing to see how their
parents are fighting every day to provide
an opportunity for them.